I have no idea what's going to happen
next normally when I do a video I have a
script under a plan but this time no
such like this is the high-voltage test
lab at the University of Manchester and
the idea is that we're going to hit one
of those with more than a million volts
from one of me I should probably get
back down this is the UK's largest
multi-purpose high-voltage lab we
basically test design and do research on
all kinds of electrical assets we also
do use the lab for teaching we have an
impulsion rate up that can go up to two
million volts historically this lab
would have been used to actually test
how lightning effects an aircraft but
we've never tested it wrong before and
it drones actually made of composite
materials plastics is it going to fry
the electricals they're going to fry the
battery or is it going to be fine what
do you think but I think it will blow up
I probably shouldn't say that should I
yeah this is the kind of capacitor that
you might buy at a local electronics
shop to put in a circuit and this is the
kind of capacitor that they use here at
the lab each one of these red boxes can
store 100 thousand volts and there are
20 of them in this tower so when the
trigger fires all that power is going to
go through the resistors in front of me
up down through that little brown wire
to the single point then it's really the
air of lightnings to the ground rod it's
just going to be a droning the way oh
there we go
[Music]
thank you
nice charging
you're not me
ah look it's not even very hot it's
actually a little bit disappointing I
was kind of holding it we live healthy
and smell others I promise you inhale
products were in mode so what I would do
is why I'll just take the pad yeah let's
see the battery house batteries in times
the private little darling let's
transfer it back on honest and a face
let go now the internal to that
batteries does the entry point is coming
through the mortage of the propeller
which is made out of metal and it seems
an exit detective a point which is
almost a handles even though they are
made out of plastic there's still a
sharp point which means that I have a
high electric field so you still will
get an exit point which is what's
happened but all that current has gone
through the motors and all the
electronics which is pretty much Friday
but it seems to skip the battery the
reason why the battery is protected the
battery does have a metal casing around
if you kind of think a solid breaks a
Faraday cage the sephardic is so dull
has probably protected the battery Ron
for everything around it has been afraid
to bits
alright what I would recommend is almost
having something sticking out from the
top yeah almost like a metal electrode
again so like a lightning interceptor so
that attaches to that point and you can
have an exit point we'll try and see if
we can put a metal tape and protruding
part outside which will hopefully
attract lightning so it doesn't go
through anything else let's do it
sorry on backup from
[Music]
laughing still we have mutation yes I
aircraft is connected all right let's
not really
okay so it glued up a paragraph man they
went
it turned see any visible when the last
one that was charring on the plastic so
we've got the picture
similar to last time seems to be
attaching to the propeller and coming
out there you go so you completely
missed the lightning rod of MIT yes at
the end of the day this actually will
tell you that lightning can be
unpredictable it's insane
yeah I am and in all fairness it did hit
the propellers again and comes at the
same point out one of the streamers when
you have a high-voltage streamers are
what go up to our self-esteem estimate
from the claim right so when both of
those connect then do you get a channel
Trevor for Thomas absolutely Hegel
they're destroyed and their dads a
stream streamer is still there look at
that channels already formed yeah so the
currents already gone through again you
can see just little blowing embers
the multimeric going now alright so
that's you back in no no it's good so
the most bids to get a fly and dromio
lightning storm don't dump Thank You
helipad I tell them thank you to
everyone at the University of
Manchester's high voltage lab pull down
the description for more about them and
please don't try this at home
if you have a high voltage laboratory